اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا
المساء
بين سوريا وتركيا لا ملامح مصالحه في
الافق وسط تمسك الطرفين بشروطهم عوده
العلاقات بحاجه للمزيد من الوساطات ام من
التنازلات
وفي موضوع النقاش الثاني
ايم قليله على موعد الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه فرص الفوز
اقرب للرئيس اردوغان ام لمرشح المعارضه
كليتش
ونحييكم الى نقاش الملف الاول بين سوريا
وتركيا طريق مصالحه طويل لا افق له كما
يقول مراقبون تصريحات متبادله في الاونه
الاخيره تؤكد ان عوده العلاقات معقوده
بشرط دمشق تطالب بانسحاب القوات التركيه
من اراضيها اولا وهو ما ترد عليه انقره
بانها لا تفكر في سحب قواتها من اراضي
سوريا على الاقل في الوقت الراهن تصريحات
وزير الدفاع التركي خلوص اكارج جاءت من
على الحدود مع سوريا التي تفقدها برفقه
الرئيس اركان الجيش وذكر فيها ان تركيا
ليست لها اطماع في اراضي احد وان وجود
قوات بلاده لا يشكل تهديدا لسوريا كارل
صرح كذلك بان تهديد الحقيقي هو الارهاب
الذي يشكل خطرا على وحده سوريا وعدم
استقرارها مضيفا ان بلاده لا تغزو الاراضي
السوريه كما لفت الى مواصله العمليات
العسكريه خلال المرحله المقبله شماليه
سوريا والع على حد سواء حتى القضاء على
اخر ارهابي وفق قوله تاتي هذه التصريحات
في وقت مشدده وزير الخارجيه فيصل المقداد
قبل ايام على وجوب انهاء وجود القوات
التركيه شمال غربي سوريا وعلى خطه
دبلوماسيه اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه التركيه
ان اتصالا هاتفيا جمع وزير خارجيتها
بنظيره الروسي ناقش خلاله الملف السوري
بما يتعلق باجتماع اللجنه الرباعيه لوزراء
الخارجيه بشان سوريا
[موسيقى]
تصريحات الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
ومسؤولين السوريين
اردوغان انسحاب الجيش من شمال سوريا سيشكل
ضعفا امنيا رد وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل
المقداد بالقول وجود القوات التركيه
والمجموعات المسلحه في شمال غربي سوريا
يجب ان ينتهي اردوغان لا نفكر بالانسحاب
لان التهديد الارهابي متواصل
المقداد اي لقاءات مع الجانب التركي يجب
ان تبنى على اسس احترام سياده سوريا ووحده
اراضيها وانهاء الاحتلال ووقف دعم الارهاب
ويضيف المقداد بالقول الوجود العسكري
التركي ودعم بعض المجموعات المسلحه يعيقان
الجهود لاصلاح العلاقات مع تركيا
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من دمشق صحفي
غسان يوسف اهلا بك من اسطنبول لمصطفى
المحلل السياسي اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام
واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من دمشق معك يا استاذ
غسان واستاذ غسان ما الذي ينقص مسار
المحادثات التركيه السوريه حتى نصل لمرحله
تطبيع الكامل هل ينقصها المزيد من الوسطات
من التاثير الخارجي او ينقصها المزيد من
التنازلات لكلا الطرفين او لاحدهما
تحياتي اهلا بك
انا
اعتقد
ينطقها الاراده الصادقه من قبل القياده
التركيه ولذلك لاحظي مثلا انهم يستعجلون
باللقاءات الدبلوماسيه ولقاءات وزراء
الدفاع واللقاءات الانبياء ولكنهم عندما
مثلا يجتمعون مع الجانب السوري وبحضور
الجانبين الايراني والروسي بعد يوم او
يومين يصرحون وعلى اكبر مستوى يعني رئيس
الجمهوريه التركيه صرح لسي ان ان
الامريكيه بانه لم ينسحب من سوريا وايضا
اليوم وزير الدفاع صرح بانه لن ينسحب وان
هذا يضعف محاربه الارهاب طيب اذا كان
محاربه الارهاب اذا كانت محاربه الارهاب
ستضعه في شمال سوريا طيب ماذا عن ادلب
التي تبعد كثيرا يعني عن مثلا قوات قتال
وماذا عن منطقه شمال اللاذقيه جبانه انا
يعني ارى بان هناك تناقضا وان هناك عدم
سوريا
التصريحات التركيه وان روسيا ربما تفشل
يعني في هذا المسعى اذا تعنت التركي بهذا
الشكل واذا يعني لاحظنا تصريحات ايضا يعني
طالبه بوضع حلب تحت الاداره التركيه ايضا
سليمان كان يجتمع مع القطريين ويبنون
وحدات سكنيه للتغيير الديمقراطي في شمال
سوريا عوضا عن ان يبحثوا هذا الملف مع
الدوله السوريه لاعاده هؤلاء الى مناطقهم
لكنهم يبنون حزاما يعني على الجانب
استاذ غسان تتحدث عن تناقض في تصريحات
التركيه تتحدث عن ازمه ثقه ولكن حضرتك
تتحدث عن شيء ملفت تقول بانه ليست هناك من
الاساس اراده تركيه لتحقيق مثل هكذا شرط
استاذ اوزجان ما رايك هل فعليا ليست هناك
اراده في داخل التركي للتنازل على شمال
غربي سوريا حتى تحقيق الاهداف وتقول تركيا
بان اهد افها هي او تتمثل في اشتثاث
الارهاب
نعم تركيا طبعا ربما تحتفظ بهذه الورقه
لانهاء وجود وحضرتي مع الشعب متعالف مع
حزب الامه الكردستاني اذا ورقه تركيا
تحتفظ بورقه الضغط ولذلك لابد ان تكون
هناك التزامات متبادله بين نظام السوري
وبين تركيا عندما نظام السوري يحارب او
ينهي وجود وحدات في معرض في هذه الحالات
تركيا طبعا تنصيب مبدئيا تركيا ليس ضد
الانسحاب
كرروا كرروا القول على ان تركيا لات مع
لها في
يعبس السوري في اراضي سوريا هذا هذا صحيح
وتركيا حاربت او تصدت لمجموعتين من
الارهابيين يعني على وصف تركيا طبعا
في مدينه الباب دوايش واضح ولكن من جهه
حضرتك تقول بان تركيا ليست لها اطماع فيما
يخص الاراضي السوريه وفي المقابل حضرتك
تقول بان هذا التواجد التركي في الداخل
السوري تستخدمه تركيا كورقه للضغط على حزب
العمال الكردستاني طيب ما الذي تريده
تركيا من سوريا كما يخص حزب العمال
الكردستاني
عندما يزول وجود وهذا فيما الشعب من شمال
سوريا تركيا حدثت مثل الثلاثين كيلو من
الهدود تركيا الى اعماق سوريا في هذه
الحاله لم يتبقى هناك مشكله التعثر بين
الطرفين تركيا وسوريا اذا هناك التزامات
متبادله كما ذكرت تركيا
تنصعب لان ليس لديها عصلا خطه للبقاء هناك
لان ليس تراب سوريا تراب تركيا ولكن
بالمقابل تركيا تريد انهاء وجود وحدات
الشعب
وحداتي الشعب احيانا يتفق مع النظام
الصوره احيانا مع الامريكيين احيانا مع
روس وغيرها
وهم يستحقفون اهداف يستهتفون اهداف او
مصالح تركيا فقط لا غير لذلك وضحت فكره
حضرتك
هذا ما قاله وزير الدفاع كذلك خلوص ياكاري
يقول بان اشتتاه الارهاب في مصلحتنا كما
في مصلحه سوريا ولكن حضرتك تحدثت عن حضور
الاكراد في الشمال وطبعا هذه نقطه استفهام
كبيره وهنا سؤال استاذ غسان
بمنطق هذا الحديث بانه يجب ان تحل اولا
مشاكل الاكراد شمال سوريا هل يمكن هل في
مقدره الحكومه السوريه التعامل اولا مع
هذا الملف قبل الحديث عن تطبيع كامل
العلاقات مع تركيا
يعني هناك تناقض كبير في حديث الضيف وفي
حديث خلوطي افكار وفي حديث الرئيس
عندما يطالب مثلا الدوله السوريه بانهاء
نفترض قوات قتال المتعامله مع الاحتلال
الامريكي فهذا
يرجع الى الولايات المتحده التي تدعم هذه
الوحدات بالسلاح والمال وتنهب النفط
السوري لكن اذا اتينا الى ادلب من الذي
يدعم مثلا جبهه النصره على الرغم من ان
تركيا يعني
اعلاميا تقول بان جبهه ارهابيه ايضا بقايا
داعش لديك حراس الدين لديك تنظيم خراسان
لديك ما يسمى التوحيد والجهاد وكلها يعني
بعضها اجنبي جاء مثلا من الشيشان من غيرها
بعضها موجود في كمال اللاذقيه يعني كان
الجنود الشام الشيشان وغيرها هؤلاء تسيطر
عليهم تركيا بالكامل تسلحهم تدعمهم لوجسيا
تدعمهم بالغذاء والدواء
في جسر الشغور هجر اهلها ويسكنها هؤلاء
تركيا لم تقم يعني لنكن صادقين وواقعيين
سوريا تطالب بخطوات مثلا هل استطاعت مثلا
او هل فتحت تركيا طريق الام فور التي
تسيطر عليه جبهه اخرى لا هل قامت بتفكيك
جبهه هل قامت بتفكيك بقايا داحش لا يعني
قاده داعش قتلوا في هذه المنطقه هل كانت
لي مثلا ترحيل التركي الثاني
وغيرهم لا اذا ماذا فعلت تركيا هي تقول
بوجود مثلا
قوات قسنطينه في شمال سوريا هذا صحيح هي
موجوده ولكن هؤلاء ابناء المنطقه اما
هؤلاء ليسوا ابناء المرض هزم
بحفره يعني هذه
المنظمه مصنفه ارهابيه اما قسم
خليني انقل فقط هذه النقطه للاستاذ مصطفى
في النهايه هذه منطقتهم هذه ارضهم ولكن
تركيا
واقتبس مقاله الاستاذ غسان تركيا تتعاون
مع مجموعات مصنفه في الاصل الارهابيه
وتتواجد كذلك في شمال السوري
مشكله تكمن انه متخلف مع حزب الامه
الكردستاني الى تركيا ويقاربون بعض
المواقع المحسوبه على الاتراك هذه هي
المشكله لذلك تركيا تريد
هذه المشكله وكانت هناك اتفاقيه قبل ذلك
[موسيقى]
مع
تركيا لا تعارض وجود اكلات هناك لا ابدا
لماذا
لا ليس هناك اي من هذا الخصوص ثانيا
بالنسبه
هم لم ياتوا من تركيا بل اتوا من جنوب
سوريا عندما
اتفقوا تفاهم مع نظام السوري انتقلوا الى
شمال سوريا الى ادلب وامه يتوقفون او
ينتظرون
يكون هناك كشفيه كشفيه السياسيه يعني
الحكومه السوريه استاذ غسان
لا لا
جبهه النصره هي جبهه مصنفه ارهابيه وكانت
موجوده في تلك المناطق وايضا هناك
الجماعات الاسلاميه المرتبطه بالقاعده
وجماعات
هو الاستاذ مصطفى يقول بانه بالتعاون مع
الحكومه السوريه جبهه النصره طلب منها ان
تغير مكانها من الجنوب الى شمال الغربي
تفضل جبهه النصره كانت متواجده في الاراضي
السوريه التي كان يعني كانت موجوده في
ادلب موجوده
في الغوطه موجوده في حلب موجوده في جنوب
سوريا هذا صحيح ولكن يعني انا اقول لك
هلال ادلب من قبل هذه القوات الارهابيه في
28 اذار 2015 كان بدعم لوجستي كبير وتسليح
ودعم بالدبابات وحتى المدفعيه
لاحتلال ادلب من قبل هذه المجموعات
الارهابيه وهذا الدعم التركي كان موثوقا
وبقي ايام كثيره وقتل الكثير
من ابناء ادلب وبدعم تركي واضح ولذلك
تعتبر هذه العمليه ان يعني تركيا انصرفت
انخراطا كبيرا في عمليه احتلال ادلب من
قبل جبهه اسمحوا لي ان اتقدم قليلا في هذا
النقاش باختصار تكرمت تفضل استاذ غسان
في نعم في عشرين مارس
عشرين عشرين او في واحد مارس كانت جبهه
النصره تتصدى
يعني الجيش العربي السوري دخلت تركيا
بقواتها لتدافع عن جبهه واعطتها اللباس
التركي والسلاح التركي ووقفت الى جانبها
ومنعت القوات الجيش العربي السوري من فتح
وتحرير هذه المنطقه ولذلك انا اقول لك
جبهه النصره صناعه تركيه وحمايه تركيه طيب
خلي ضيفي يعلق فقط على هذه النقطه
هل كان تركيا في غوطه حتى صلاهم او نظمهم
لا لا هذا كلام لا يحتاج الى ديل او الى
الى الرد
جبهه وصلنا ونقصه بنفسه ليس هناك اي تدخل
تركيا بل هناك نظام اساء على شعبه لذلك
امتلكوا عن بعض الموضوع منظمات امتلكوا من
هذه الارضيه ليحارب النظام السوري اولا
بالنسبه من اللحظه بالنسبه للاكراد هذا
متنازع بين تركيا والنظام السوري لان هم
امتداد لحزب الامه الكردستان بالنسبه
لقضيه ادلب قضيه ادلب ينتظر تسويه
السياسيه بين نظام سوري وبين هذه المجموعه
هذه المجموعات ليس لديهم اي سلامات تركيا
ولكن تركيا تريد ايضا ان يكون هناك تسويه
سياسيه المجتمع الدولي كذلك يريد ان يكون
هناك تسويه سياسيه لان هناك نصوص صادره من
الامم المضطهده ينص على ذلك ولكن نظام
السوري ينفلت
من المسؤوليات هذا هو الواقع استاذ مصطفى
طالما حضرتك طرحت موضوع التسويه السياسيه
اسمح لي ان تقدم في النقاش وان نناقش كذلك
هذه الجزئيه حضرتكم تتذكرون بانه في اول
هذه السنه كان هناك حديث وهذا الحديث
اطلقه على فكره وزير الدفاع التركي خنوصي
اكار تحدث فيه عن لجنه ثلاثيه تضم روسيا
سوريا وتركيا لمحاوله ان تكون هناك
مجموعات
او عمليات في الشمال السوري ولكن بعد فتره
في زيارته الاخيره لهذه المناطق نفسه خلص
اكار تحدث عن لجنه كما قال هو مشتركه ولكن
رباعيه انضافت ايران سيد غسان
لماذا تضاف ايران الى هذه اللجنه بينما
كان الحديث عن ثلاث دول ستشرف على دوريات
ستشرف على وجود على مسك الارض حتى انهاء
تواجد ما سمي بالارهاب في شمال السوري ما
الذي تفعله ايران مجددا بحسب فلوس اكار
لكان هناك صناعه
بين البلدين بين تركيا وسوريا
ظهر الاستماع العلني في 28 ديسمبر العام
الماضي اخر العام الماضي باجتماع وزراء
الدفاع روسيا سوريا تركيا من بعدها انضمت
ايران الى هذا الاستماع واصبح رباعيا
وشاهدنا اجتماع يعني عشره مارس الذي كان
دواب وزراء الخارجيه ومن ثم خمسه وعشرين
ابريل نيسان اجتمع ايضا وزراء الدفاع ومن
ثم اجتمع وزراء الخارجيه انا اقول لك حتى
الان ليس هناك لجان وهذا ما نقدته سوريا
بسبب التعنت التركي وبسبب عدم تصريحات
التركيه بانه لا انسحاب من الاراضي
السوريه
الاستاذ غسان اسمحلي فقط اي عقل ان لا
تكون هناك ديجان لان وزير الدفاع التركي
اكد في زرته الاخيره وقال ان هناك مركز
مشترك هكذا اسماه يضم
[موسيقى]
من هذه المجلس المجلس الجديد رباعي كانه
هو امتداد بالنسبه
لذلك هي دخلت دخلت على الخط
يقول ولكن كما ذكرت لو كان اسمح لي فقط
مع المعارضه ولكن ضيف يقول لك ليست هناك
مؤشرات لم نرى شيء جديد فيما يخص هذه
اللجان او مراكز مشتركه وخلوصي اكار اكد
على ذلك وساقرا لحضراتكم مقاله قال قلنا
لننشئ مركزا مشتركا في سوريا
لنترك الجنود هناك سنتابع الانشطه على
الفور سنتخذ الاحتياطات اللازمه حيل هذه
التطورات اتفقنا على ذلك كما اتفقنا على
استمرار المفاوضات هذا ما قاله خلاص اكارم
منذ فتره قصيره من على خط الحدود السوري
التركي سيد مصطفى هل يمكن ان يكون هناك
تفاهم دون اخذ بعين الاعتبار الموقف
السوري
بالنسبه يعني كانت هناك اصلا جلست في جانف
وغيرها بين المعارضه والهكم في سوريا لسن
دستور الجديد ولكن لم يلتزم نظام سوري
بل اقصاهم
اقصاهم لذلك
تركيا لا تتعلق اصلا في هذه القضيه لماذا
تتعنت في هذه القضيه ولكن ولكن الذي يتعنت
اصلا هو النظام السوري
يستطيع ان يباشر في الملاحظات والمحادثات
مع مع شعبه المتفرع عن شعبي بعض المنظمات
او بعض الفصائل ولا يحتاج الى تركيا اذا
كانت هناك تسويه سياسيه هل تركيا لا
يستطيع ان يتدخل لا اذا كانت هناك مجموعه
رباعيه تركيه طبعا
تتباهس مع مع العناصر الاخرى ثلاثيه ولكن
عندما يكون هناك طعنق من الطرف
من الطرف ما لا يتقدم هذه المباحثات حولها
المواضيع المتعلقه او عالقه طيب استاذ
غسان هل يمكن لهذا المركز المشترك والذي
تحدث عنه وزير الدفاع التركي خلوص هل يمكن
فعليا بحسب قراءه حضرتك ان يحدث اختراق
حقيقي لمسار المحادثات التركيه السوريه
اذا كان هناك نيه صادقه يعني من الجانب
التركي انا اقول لك نعم ولكن حتى الان لم
نلحظ اي شيء يعني على الارض يعني مثلا في
اتفاق
يعني عشرين عشرين بين بوتين كان هناك
اتفاق على فتح طريق الانفورد وان يكون
هناك يعني ابعاد المسلحين سته كيلو متر
شمال وسته كيلو متر جنوب لم ينفذ هذا
الاتفاق كان هناك اتفاقات كثيره لم تنفذ
لم تنفذ شيء كان هناك ان تقوم تركيا مثلا
المجموعات الارهابيه المطلقه ارهابيا ومن
اعجبتني لم تقم تركيا باي شيء لذلك انا
اقول لك ليس هناك اي ثقه من الجانب السوري
بالجانب التركي ونحن نعرف يعني لان
اردوكان براك ماتي يعني هو اليوم قادم على
انتخابات هو يريد ان يظهر بانه يسعى
لاعاده اللاجئين ولكن لا يفعل شيء على
الارض هو يريد هو يقول بانني اريد مباحثات
مع سوريا ولكن
استاذ غسان مهما حسابات اردوغان اذا كانت
هناك عدم اراده تركيه بحسب قولك اذا كانت
هناك عدم ثقه بين الطرفين طيب سؤال بسيط
لماذا تركيا تمسك هذه الارض البعض يقول
تغيير ديموغرافي هي تهدف لذلك حضرتك تتفق
مع هذه القراءه او لك قراءه اخرى مثلا في
خصوص مسك تركيا لهذه الرقعه من الارض وهي
ممتده يعني طولا 400 كم
يعني عمقا يقال بانه تخطط حتى 30 كيلومتر
المتفق عليها منذ البدايه
تعطيني وقت الحلقه الماضيه الحلقه الماضيه
انا قلت لك عن الميثاق الملي
الذي يعني تتمسك به تركيا حتى الان يعني
مثلا بهذا العام سنفذ الذكرى المئويه
لمعاهده لوزان في 24 يوليو
والسيد اردوغان دائما ما يهاجم اتفاقيه هو
يتمسك بالمشاق الذي اقره مجلس النواب
العثماني او الموعد المبعوثان العثماني
1920 ولذلك لاحظي لان كل الاراضي التي
دخلتها تركيا تقوم مثلا ببناء مؤسسات
تركيه العمله التركيه موجوده الكهرباء
التركيه موجوده المدارس التركيه موجوده
التدريس اللغه التركيه موجوده مستوطنات
اصبحت تبنى باموال القطريه كل شيء يبنى
على اساس ان تركيا لن تخرج ولذلك هناك نعم
تغيير ديمقراطيه هناك ترتيل مثلا للعرب من
هذه المناطق وبناء احزمه تركمانيه هو يريد
ان يضم هذه المناطق ولكن لا يستطيع هذه
ليست المره الاولى التي تحدث فيها حضرتك
عن مطامع اردوغان العثمانيه ولكن اليست
هناك مبالغه كذلك في طرح
استاذ مصطفى الكلمه الكلمه لحضرتك تفضل
استاذ
ليس هناك تغيير ديمقراطي ديموغرافي بلومي
وغيرهم من السياسيين في تركيا يرون ان
هناك تغيير ديمقراطي بسبب وجود اللاجئين
السوريين الذين اتوا الى تركيا اذا الرؤيه
من جانب وايت هذا غير صحيح ابدا الروس
طلبوا من تركيا طبعا تسليم
طريق المعروف
[موسيقى]
ولكن ايضا هناك انفور انفور ولكن هناك
بالمقابل كانوا يسلمون تالي رفض وغيرها
الى السلطات تركيا او هنا وجود وحدات
الشعب
ولكن هم لم يلتزموا ايضا اذا لم يكن
التزام من الطرفين في هذه الطرف الثاني
ايضا لا يلتزم ولكن
فقط لادقق معك
من يجب ان يقدم هذا الطريق تقول الحكومه
السوريه
تقول بانه هناك تعهد صحيح ولكن تقول حضرتك
سيد اجران بان هذا الطريق الانفور يجب او
ان يكون هناك تعهد بتسليمه من سيسلمه لمن
هو في ايدي روسيا صحيح
لا مش في ايت روسيا
ليس التزام واحد من جانب واحد بل هناك
التزامات من الطرفين يعني الطرف الثاني
اذا يلتزم نبيه ترهضاتي في هذه الاله تسقط
التزامات للطرف الثاني ايضا يعني لتركيا
لذلك روسيا وغيرها اعطى نظام سوري لم
يلتزم لا لا لم يكن اصلا بين تركيا
نظام سوري اتفاقيه ولكن بين روسيا بتركيا
على هذا الاساس تم اتفاق على انفور
وايضا وغيرها كان يعني من المفروض ان يسلم
او يطرد فيها عناصر المنتميه لي وعظاتي
لم تنفذ هذه البنوط لذلك طرف التركي ايضا
لم تلتزم اذا يعني بتوقيت
بتوقيت هذه الاتفاقيه طيب على كل يبدو بان
طريق طويل قبل عوده العلاقات الطبيعيه
تماما كما كانت او ربما سنشهد مشاهده
مفاجاه عفوا اذا صدقت تصريحات وزير الدفاع
خلوصي اقار ونتاج شيء غير معلن حتى الان
عن مركز هذا المركز المشترك ساكتفي معكم
بهذا القدر اشكركم الجزيل الشكر على
الحضور والمشاركه من دمشق الصحفي غسان
يوسف ومن اسطنبول مصطفى غجران المحلله
السياسي شكرا لكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات